connaître et savoir reconnaître les
insectes auchan c'est primordial quand
on est agriculteur parce que certains
sont des alliés des cultures penser aux
pollinisateurs par exemple alors que
d'autres peuvent être des ravageurs pour
les aider à identifier ces petites bêtes
voici un homme qui pratique un métier
pour le moins insolite
[Musique]
à première vue l'endroit donne envie de
prendre ses jambes à son cou c'est
pourtant ici que travail joseph moisins
de serre il se prépare à réaliser une
séance photo qui demande patience et
minutie et les modèles qu'il doit
immortaliser son minuscule et parfois
très capricieux il photographie des
insectes
[Musique]
des fois ça peut prendre quelques
centaines de photos avant d'en avoir une
qui va être vraiment aussi bien qu
est-ce qu on le désire
joseph moysan de serre nourrit une
passion pour les insectes depuis
l'enfance un livre offert par son grand
père lui fait découvrir un papillon
mythique qui l'obsède jusqu'à ce qu'il
finisse par le capturer à l'âge de 19
ans avec l'aide d'un ami au moment où on
allait partir
on s'est emballé par le dernier petit
tour pour voir si on peut si on ne
répond qu' avec qui ce qui serait arrivé
puis comme des faits le papillon en
question est arrivé à ce moment là puis
ben je les attrape et pour ça je me suis
mis à danser
c'est le cas de capture c'était vraiment
un moment charnière dans mon amour pour
les insectes dans mon dans maintenant ma
passion que dans mon intérêt à en faire
afin de l'entomologie ma carrière
aujourd'hui biologiste entomologiste au
ministère de l'agriculture des pêcheries
et de l'alimentation et l'identifient et
photographies des 1 s'est souvent
jusqu'à une centaine par jour de toutes
les couleurs et de tous les formats
généralement plus c'est petit plus c'est
un gros défi grand qu'on travaille avec
des il faut des gars qui sont
microscopiques l'ipsa carrier qui sont
vraiment mots seulement quelques
dixièmes de millimètres certaines
bestioles n'apprécie pas de se retrouver
sous les feux de la rampe
plutôt que de prendre la pose elles
prennent la fuite
donc à ce moment là on peut utiliser des
techniques particulières ont volé
réfrigérée et on va les mettre dans des
petits pots pour les calmer on va les
mettre dans le noir pour justement
essayer de les calmer pour les rendre un
peu plus docile pendant la session de
photos d'autres insectes ont recours un
subterfuge surprenant pour éviter les
flashes des photographes
il ya des insectes qui leur mode de
défense c'est de simplement se laisser
tomber lorsqu'il ya un prédateur qui
s'approche d'eux et qu'ils sont sur la
plante qui sont dans rain man g
[Musique]
le problème ne se pose pas dans cette
partie du studio les insectes
photographie ici sont morts est monté
sur des épingles les équipements de
macrophotographie sont sophistiquées et
les spécimens doivent être complètement
immobile son système maison ou ses
objectifs téléphoto sur le temps de
monter une lente et de microscope pour
est capable de vraiment leurs
photographies des choses qui sont
microscopiques
juste à côté cet appareil permet de
prendre plusieurs photos en couche à
l'horizontale un programme informatique
fusionnent ensuite les photos pour
dévoiler une foule de détails invisibles
à l'oeil nu mais ce qui trouble la
pointe de cartons qui était monté ici
dans les faits lorsqu'on le regarde de
près ça ressemble à ce qu'on connaissait
qui est vraiment très très joli teint
couleur plein de des textures
différentes plein de poils
[Musique]
d'autres photos sont assemblés en
collage est monté pour en faire une
vidéo qui permet de mieux voir la
bestiole sous tous ses angles grâce à
son art
joseph arrive même à saisir la beauté et
la complexité des mal aimés les insectes
ravageurs qu'il photographie souvent
dans le cadre de son travail
est ce que une photographie noter
particulièrement fiable il y en a
plusieurs dans le sud ont enregistré
terre mais je dirais que cette motion a
été un point tournant pour moi dans la
photographie
j'ai fait deux sets côté la fileuse mr
là je pense qu'on arrive à quelque chose
de vraiment intéressant de produit
capable justement de faire voyager les
gens ou faire voir aux gens là la beauté
même d'un insecte qui me semble trop
vulgaire
joseph moysan de serre est devenu une
référence au québec pour
l'identification des insectes notamment
des insectes ravageurs de cultures un
important réseau de collaborateurs lui
envoie des spécimens des échantillons
d'un peu partout dans la province de
producteurs agricoles d'agronomes de
n'importer qui s'appelle de particuliers
aussi dans certains échos qui
s'intéressent à l'agriculture ou qui ont
des problématiques particulières avec
les insectes
cette montagne d'échantillons a été reçu
dans la journée
l'été en période de pointe le
laboratoire identifie jusqu'à 200
spécimens par semaine
ce printemps le laboratoire à d'ailleurs
identifié un parasite des colonies
d'abeilles
nouvellement arrivée au québec et qui
menace la production de miel table
importants sinon quelques avons fait
effectivement identification plus
formelle de collecte à la ruche c'est
ainsi que les chansons qui sont
récoltées par par les inspecteurs du
mapaq sont acheminés joseph contribue
aussi à alimenter la collection
d'insectes du québec
géré par le ministère de l'agriculture
des pêcheries et de l'alimentation et le
ministère des forêts de la faune et des
parcs
avec ses quelque 200 mille spécimens
c'est l'une des plus importantes
collections de la province vous montrez
le fameux spécimens qui a en quelque
sorte un changer ta vie ça donc ça c'est
le fameux papillon aux lunes qui est un
papillon vraiment vraiment fabuleux
encore une fois quand je regarde
aujourd'hui c'est toujours toujours le
même
éblouissement maintien je regarde ses
couleurs sa forme tout va bien on est
juste parfait
grâce à ses talents de photographe
joseph peut mieux faire apprécier
l'univers méconnu des insectes de
petites bestioles complexe et fascinant
si des organismes je trouve tellement
profondément joly est intéressant que je
ressens un peu dommage de voir que tant
de gens que ça repousse qui semble pour
ce que je fais de la photo c'est que ça
me montre la beauté profondes de ces
petites bêtes là qu'on n'est pas capable
de devoir aller unis
[Musique]